normalerweise wenn ich hier sitze rege
ich mich über irgendwas auf oder ich
höre mich über irgendjemanden oder
irgendwas diesmal möchte ich jemanden
meinen respekt ausdrücken nämlich armin
laschet ist ein mann der gerade an
diesem ort oft kritisiert wurde der oft
durch den kakao gezogen wurde ich finde
jetzt ist im moment auch mal im respekt
zu zollen weil er in puncto umgang mit
niederlagen einfach
vorbildlich ist im moment eher hat
erinnern wir uns kurz zurück er ist als
erfolgreicher ministerpräsident in den
wahlkampf gestartet scheiterte dann
letztlich an angela merkel die ihm eine
inhalt los entkernte cdu hinterlassen
hat und ihm auch nicht wirklich im
wahlkampf unterstützt hat er scheiterte
an edmund stoiber als schriebe edmund
stoiber an markus söder der hat sich
ständig gegen ihn gestellt hat und
zuletzt über ein lapsus diesen lacher
wer ehrlich gesagt uns allen hätte
geschehen können aber wie er damit
umgeht wie jetzt wird sondern die werke
umgeht fällig ist wirklich bringt mir
respekt ab er hat den anderen
ministerpräsidenten niedergelegt
er hat die verantwortung für die volle
verantwortung für diese historische
niederlage der cdu übernommen und gibt
den weg einer cdu spitze frei und hat
sich mit einer respektablen rede in
goslar aus der ersten reihe der politik
verabschiedet ich finde das verdient
respekt
alexander das kann man der respektvoll
finden da wichtiger nicht widersprechen
nur das ist im grunde eine realität die
arena schütte anerkennen muss das ist
der letzte schritt im politischen
überlebenskampf und der rückzug aus der
ersten reihe der politik auf die
hinterbank so ist es für ihn und wir
müssen auch konstatieren lange wollte er
das gar nicht wahrhaben er war jemand
der spät erst olaf scholz gratuliert hat
er war auf verschiedenen öffentlichen
veranstaltungen zum zuletzt auf dem
parteitag der jungen union war immer
noch den eindruck erweckt hat das passt
schon irgendwie das kann schon mit der
ampel mit der mit der leica koalition
und es wurde dann wie wir gesehen haben
die ampel also angela merkel hat oder
ich heute zum wahlsieg gratuliert als
armin laschet
das ist jetzt der letzte schritt aber
ich finde das auch eine debatte von
gestern mich interessiert vielmehr was
wird jetzt aus der cdu wird das jetzt
eine splitterpartei teilen die sich die
reinen rechten eben mit der csu zusammen
die andere mit der cdu wollen die
doppelspitze ist es auf dem weg nach
parteien splitterpartei zu werden wie
den niederlanden oder eine rechtspartei
oder der weg in die bedeutungslosigkeit
das ist was mich interessiert war ist
das kann man bedauern aber es ist so
dass am ende dabei keine rolle mehr
spielt wird will ich möchte doch noch
einmal bei alexanders punkt bleiben dem
ich auch komplett recht gebe mehr
respekt vor auf den wahlverlierern und
da es aber auch direkte frage nicht mich
hat die debattenkultur schon schockiert
und wie sehr in den boden gerammt wurde
hat mich auch schockieren das hat mich
damals schon bei martin schulz auch
schockiert ob wir somit kandidaten
umgehen müssen meine frage sind nicht
wenige regierungssprecher unter gerhard
schröder war das damals auch schon so
zum beispiel ich würde jetzt sagen ich
hab's nicht miterlebt aber edmund
stoiber ist doch danach eine rentable
persönlichkeit geblieben aber johannes
rau hatten das gleiche bei johannes rau
johannes rau ist auch ministerpräsident
geblieben willy brandt ist mehrfach
wieder gekommen wo er noch als
außenminister kalibriert und das deutsch
unsere kandidaten so gegen und wann wir
haben eine gute umgang mit verlieren
also dass das hat das hat doch nicht
nicht folgen jetzt ist doch kein dass
armin laschet beispiel zurückgetreten
ist als ministerpräsident hat auch
nichts zu tun mit dem wahlkampf oder
seinem verlust das hat er vorher
angekündigt und das haben weder edmund
stoiber gemacht noch hätte es noch hat
es auch willy brandt war damals mal
regierender bürgermeister von berlin
dennoch hat es johannes rau gemacht im
gegenteil johannes rau da gab es einmal
eine phase als der bundespräsident wurde
da hat er aber klar die zusage dass er
dann bundespräsident wird nach einem
interregnum von einem jahr nein das hat
armin laschet ja selber gesagt wohl das
kann man nun gut finden oder auch im
wissen doch zugeben dass sein ruf als
erfolg schon gesagt ja aber ob er jetzt
haltbar geblieben wäre als
ministerpräsident von von bisher auch
mein heim bundeslehrer heimat bundesland
nordrhein-westfalen der ruf wurden die
damals auch so dermaßen ramponiert bei
ich hab schon das war doch ganz andere
lage wir hatten 16 jahren helmut kohl
mit einer entsprechenden muss man
vermacht und von deutschland nach 16
jahren wir hatten die agenda 2010 wir
hatten das nein zum irakkrieg was
natürlich zu einer unglaublichen
aufheizung der situation geführt hat die
erste rot-grüne regierung leute dachten
das ist der untergang des abendlandes
tvo aber jede woche in den politischen
talkshows die vertreter von arbeitgebern
und gewerkschaften saßen und beide von
zwei seiten auf die regierung
einprügelten habt ihr irgendwann als
arbeitgeber mal gesehen in den letzten
meinetwegen zwölf jahren von diesen 16
jahren großer koalition er zwölf jahren
großer koalition geht irgendwelchen
talkshow ausmaßen und große debatten
geführt hat da gab es aber keinen weil
wir eine beruhigung des vor politischen
raums hatten und deswegen war es auch so
ruhig wie sind alle
tranquilizer haben wir eingeschmissen in
den letzten jahren und großen duells
super er die große konsens und insofern
waren die auseinandersetzungen zwischen
design alles war herta früher aber das
war eine ganz andere die geführt worden
sind und jetzt zu sagen der armin
laschet zu erdulden hatte die cdu geht
sehr sehr hart normalerweise mit
wahlverlierern um das ist so gewesen bei
rainer barzel in den 70er jahren und
jedem anderen der es nicht vermocht hat
auch auf landesebene die erwartungen zu
erfüllen und das hat jetzt armin laschet
erlebt aber so ist es halt ich glaube
das ist in anderen ländern auch
total üblich dass man hart mit den
verlierern um gibt es ist ja kein
deutsches phänomen also wenn man nach
england schaut oder nach amerika schaut
das passiert immer ich halte ja lautet
auch für einen sehr integren menschen
und auch für wirklich einen einen guten
mann muss man sagen der war wenn das
eine reality show gewesen wäre würde man
sagen dass das eher schlecht gekostet
war ganz einfach ich glaube für manche
war es ja von anfang klar dass er ja für
das das amt oder für diese rolle als
spitzenkandidat oder das kanzlerkandidat
nicht geeignet ist ganz einfach und
jetzt muss er mit den mit den
konsequenzen leben leider ja und er muss
sitzen umringt von all denjenigen die es
leicht über ihn gesprochen haben und mit
seinen freunden oder einen anderen wir
auch in der lage ist ja das totale
risiko eingegangen das hat er ja gewusst
genauso wie martin schulz vor vier
jahren und naja jetzt können sie nehmen
das sitzen und und geschichten weiß noch
nicht ob wir wirklich gut mit unserer
politischen talenten umgehen natürlich
ist laschet bisschen bis ein bisschen zu
alt um noch als talent zu gelten aber im
prinzip muss sich dementsprechend in
england ist es vollkommen anders zum
beispiel werden bei der tory party ein
leadership contest stattfindet dann
melden sie das aus der ganzen partei
auch leute die weniger die wenig chancen
haben wie versuchen sich damit einer
starken rede nach vorne zu
spielen dann wird um mit unglaublich
harten bandagen gegeneinander gekämpft
am ende überlebt einer aber die anderen
kommen sofort wieder sind teil des
politischen personals sind nicht
plötzlich im politischen aus also wenn
jeder wenn jeder von ihrer automatischen
politischen aus landet berauben uns
natürlich auch politischer politischer
talent also ich möchte sagen würde du
hast recht laschet ist es vielleicht ein
bisschen zurück gegriffen zurück gewann
aber was ist ihnen jetzt wegen wesens
weitergeht wir haben in der cdu leute
wie jens spahn wir haben auch den wert
den man begehen jetzt alle klagen dann
haben wir natürlich heutigen haben immer
noch da haben wir den gerade gesehen
wenn sie sehr jungen am tor stellt euch
mal vor die würden sich jetzt in einer
englischen modell miteinander
miteinander kämpfen um den parteivorsitz
wenn nur noch einer übrig bleibt müssten
die anderen drei verschwinden dann
wieder unser